[Music]  from baslerman  the director who reimagined shakespeare  reinvented the musical  and redefined a classic  comes a full new vision of an american  icon  but this ain't no nostalgia show  we're gonna do something different  comic book heroes all find their  superpowers  elvis found music  uh bring that base up jerry i wish to  promote you mr presley i believe i can  be great  some people wanted to put me in jail the  whale's moving down so much as wiggle a  finger  [Music]  [Applause]  in that moment elvis the man  was sacrificed  and elvis the god was born  i would do anything to make sure my mom  and daddy never had to live in poverty  ever again  [Music]  colonel you put an end to your boy's  animal behavior or we will  [Music]  more  i am a promoter that is what i do  what do you say is god-given so there  can't be nothing wrong with it  [Music]  are you ready to fly i'm ready to fly  [Music]  you